au journaliste de la bbc cette femme
ukrainienne raconte l'horreur et le
drame qu'elle a subi le 7 mars des
soldats ont fait irruption dans son
foyer à une soixantaine de kilomètres à
l'ouest de kiev
un soldat est entré chez nous où je me
trouvais avec mon mari il a pointé son
arme sur moi et m'a emmenée de force
dans une maison voisine il m'a ordonné
de me déshabiller sinon il me tuerait
puis il m'a violée pendant qu'il me
violer quatre autres soldats sont entrés
je me suis dit que j'allais y passer
mais ils sont partis avec lui anna dont
le prénom a été modifié ajoute qu'elle a
ensuite découvert son mari blessé d'une
balle dans l'abdomen il est mort deux
jours plus tard il est difficile
d'évaluer précisément l'ampleur des
crimes sexuels commis par les forces
russes pendant leurs occupations et lors
de l'avancée des troupes mais les
témoignages de viols continuent
d'abonder et c'est généralement lors du
retrait des troupes russes que leurs
exactions sont révélés
von et prenez je dire une lutte convives
j'ai connaissance de faits avérés de
viols et d'actes de torture qui sprinte
opaque
il faut comprendre qu ils veulent que
nous ayons peur ils veulent saper notre
espoir et faire de nous des victimes
mais nous ne sommes pas des victimes nos
filles et nos femmes ukrainiennes ne
sont pas des victimes d'un régime qui
est inquiétant billets najac
lors d'une réunion du conseil de
sécurité lundi la directrice de l'
agence onusienne en charge des droits
des femmes a réclamé l'ouverture d'une
enquête sur les crimes sexuels et les
actes de tortures infligées aux femmes
des pratiques utilisées comme arme de
guerre selon elle et de nombreuses ong
mais dans cette enceinte du conseil de
sécurité la russie dispose d'un droit de
veto qui peut bloquer toute initiative
collective en ce sens